S
ALWAYS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: TALKING HEADS OF THE
MEDIA WERE SIMPLY AMAZED BY JOE
BIDEN WANTS SPEECH LAST NIGHT.
LISTEN.
>> IT WAS A VERY STRONG SPEECH
DELIVERED WELL, STARTED WELL,
ENDED WELL.
YOU COULD HEAR THE THUNDERING
APPLAUSE.
>> IT WAS A FAIRLY SOLID
PERFORMANCE.
>> I THINK THIS IS A REMINDER OF
WHY PEOPLE ELECTED JOE BIDEN.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS JOE BIDEN
AT HIS BEST.
UNCLE JOE IS BACK.
>> Jesse: THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PAID TO PRAISE BIDEN.
BUT WE WANTED TO HEAR WHAT
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T GETTING PAID
TO PRAISE HIM THINK SO WE SPOKE
TO REAL PEOPLE.
>> BIG SPEECH LAST NIGHT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> IT WAS A GOOD SPEECH.
I THINK.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT SPEECH I'M
TALKING ABOUT?
>> NO.
>> IT WAS GREAT.
I ENJOYED IT A LOT.
>> WHAT SPEECH DO YOU THINK I'M
TALKING ABOUT?
>> UH, I DON'T KNOW.
>> THE STATE OF THE UNION.
>> OH REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> OH, SHOOT.
YEAH, CRAZY STUFF IS GOING ON.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHO DELIVERED THE
STATE OF THE UNION?
>> NO.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> OH, REALLY?
>> HE IS A HYPOCRITE.
>> ALL TALK, NO ACTION.
A LOT OF MUMBLING?
>> IT WAS HORRIBLE.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THE
STATE OF THE UNION IS STRONG.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY WEAK.
>> IT'S NOT.
>> WHERE?
I DON'T SEE IT PEOPLE ARE STILL
STARCHING.
>> I DON'T THINK HE HAS PROVEN
HIMSELF YET.
INFLATION IS AT ALL TIME HIGH.
OUR GAS PRICES ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH.
>> WE NEED BRING BACK SOME OF
THE OLD TRUMP POLICIES AND WE
WILL SEE HOW STRONG THINGS
REALLY GET.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THAT HE
GETS THAT INFLATION HURTS.
DO YOU THINK.
>> NO HE IS A MAN OF MONEY AND
POWER.
>> INFLATION DOESN'T HURT HIM.
>> PROBABLY DOESN'T AFFECT HIS
BANK ACCOUNT TOO MUCH.
ESPECIALLY ALL THAT MONEY HIS
FAMILY HAS IN UKRAINE.
>> HE LIVES IN A BUBBLE IN A
CLOUD IN THE SKY AND ISN'T HERE
IN THE STREETS WITH US.
>> HE GOES BACK TO HIS -- THE
LITTLE RICH HOUSE AND HE HAS GOT
MONEY SO HE DOESN'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE POOR OR ANYBODY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THAT
EVERYTHING SHOULD BE MADE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> STAMPING PRODUCTS MADE IN
AMERICA.
>> DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
BUYING RUSSIAN OIL.
>> OH HELL NO.
>> NO, WE HAVE MORE THAN ENOUGH
OIL IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY SHOULD OPEN THE PIPELINE.
>> WHY WOULD WE BUY STUFF FROM
THEM.
>> WE BUY OIL, THE MONEY CHANGES
HAND, PUTIN HAS MONEY, AND NOW
HE INVADES UKRAINE WITH THAT
SAME MONEY.
>> AREN'T WE SUPPORTING THE
RUSSIAN WAR?
>> AT THE END OF BIDEN'S SPEECH
LAST NIGHT HE SAID GO GET HIM.
>> GO GET HIM.
>> WHO IS HE TALKING ABOUT.
>> HE IS TALKING ABOUT, I WOULD
THINK ON THE SHORT-TERM THE
RUSSIANS.
>> PROBABLY THE RUSSIANS.
>> THE RUSSIANS.
>> HE IS DEFINITELY SAYING, YOU
KNOW, COMING FOR RUSSIA'S NECK.
>> TRUMP?
>> WHOEVER HE WANTS TO SNIFF
NEXT?
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF HE KNOWS
THAT.
>> HE AIN'T GOING TO GET NOBODY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN FIRST YEAR IN
OFFICE WHAT GRADE WOULD YOU GIVE
HIM?
>> A C.
>> C MINUS.
>> A D.
>> GOOD STRONG D.
>> GOOD STRONG D?
>> YES.
>> HE IS AN E.
>> THERE IS NO E.
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO MAKE
AN E FOR THIS EXAMPLE.
>> F.
EPIC FAILURE.
>> JOE BIDEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORDS BUT IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO
ACT MORE LIKE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY.
♪
>> Jesse: WOW.
JOINING ME NOW TO BREAK IT DOWN
KELLYANNE CONWAY, FORMER
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT THAT
IS IN MIDTOWN MANHATTAN, THAT IS
NOT THE DEEP RED SOUTH,
KELLYANNE, THAT'S NO GOOD.
THAT IS NO GOOD.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> JESSE, YOU WOULD GET THAT
REACTION NO MATTER WHERE YOU
ARE REACTION FROM TWO IN
CONGRESS.
TWO OF THEM HAD RESPONSES TO
THEIR OWN PRESIDENT'S STATE OF
THE UNION.
YOU CAN TALK TO PEOPLE IN
MID-ATLANTIC.
THEY PROBABLY THINK HE IS THE
MAYOR OF WILMINGTON.
THAT'S WHERE HE SPENDS MOST OF
HIS TIME.
THE PRESIDENT MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY.
EVERY PRESIDENT HAS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY DURING THE STATE OF
THE UNION TO DO A COUPLE THINGS.
JOE BIDEN DID NONE OF THEM.
PROJECT STRENGTH, BUILD
CONFIDENCE, CRITICS AND UPEND
YOUR NAYSAYERS BY REALLY FOOLING
THEM BY DELIVERING A GREAT
PERFORMANCE WHAT THEY THINK OF
YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID THAT ALL
FOUR YEARS.
I REMEMBER AFTER HIS FIRST JOINT
SESSION OF CONGRESS WHICH IS
WHAT IT IS CALLED THE FIRST YEAR
AND NOT THE STATE OF THE UNION.
EVERYBODY SAID OH WHERE HAS
TRUMP BEEN?
MY GOODNESS.
IS HE SO MEASURED AND SO FUNNY
AND SO SERIOUS.
THAT'S WHAT THE VOTERS HAD SEEN
ALL ALONG.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WITH BIDEN LAST
NIGHT.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE HE WAS
CHECKING A BOX.
ALMOST LIKE HE WAS LANSING A
BOIL AND SMOOTHING OUT A BUMP.
SOMEWHERE HE HAD TO BE THAT
NIGHT ON THE SCHEDULE INSTEAD OF
PROJECTING STRENGTH AND
OPTIMISM.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS
CONFOUNDING TO ME AND I THINK IF
THIS WEREN'T SO YOU WOULD HAVE
HEARD DIFFERENTLY FROM THE
PEOPLE YOU INTERVIEWED TODAY,
JESSE.
THEY REALLY DID NOT DO WHAT
PRESIDENTS AND FIRST LADIES DO
IN THE GUEST BOX.
YOU HAD TO SHOW GUESTS, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE FROM D-DAY.
ELEVATING A TUSKEGEE AIRMEN TO
BIG DEER GENERAL.
A WOMAN WHO HAD OVERCOME HER
DRUG ADDICTION BEING REUNITED
FOR THE FIRST TIME WITH HER
FAMILY.
THE FAMILY BEING UNITED A
MILITARY DISSIDENT COMING ON
CRUTCHES THAT HE USED TO ESCAPE
KOREA IN 2006 IT GOES ON AND ON.
WE DIDN'T SEE MUCH OF THAT AT
ALL.
WE SAW TWO BORED WOMEN BEHIND
JOE BIDEN AND JOE BIDEN BORING
US.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE SO RIGHT.
THEY COULD HAVE PUT ON A RUSSIAN
DISSIDENT.
THEY COULD HAVE PUT ON A WORLD
WAR II VETERAN WHO FOUGHT THE
RUSSIANS IN EASTERN EUROPE.
THEY COULD HAVE PUT ON COVID
NURSE.
THEY COULD HAVE PUT ON A LITTLE
KID WHO DOESN'T HAVE TO WEAR A
MASK IN SCHOOL ANYMORE.
YOU SORE RIGHT.
THEY COULD HAVE DONE SO MANY
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE REALLY
GALVANIZED THE COUNTRY AND HE
JUST SWUNG AND HE MISSED.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE HE DIDN'T EVEN
SWING.
IT'S LIKE HE DIDN'T EVEN TRY,
KELLYANNE.
>> IT'S 89 TIME TO SHOWCASE
EVERY DAY HEROES.
ALSO THE TIME, I BELIEVE, TO
ANNOUNCE NEW POLICIES.
ALL HE DID WAS DELIVER -- ALL HE
DID WAS MAKE NEW PROMISES.
ALSO, YOU KNOW, DON'T BLAME JOE
BIDEN, MOST PRESIDENTS GET UP
THERE AND TALK ABOUT THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
HE REALLY DOESN'T HAVE ANY.
I DON'T SEE THAT AS A PARTISAN I
SAW THAT AS SINCERITY.
HE HAS NO ENERGY POLICY AND A
GUY WHO HAS NO ENERGY AT ALL.
IT WAS A DOUBLE WHAMMY FOR HIM
LAST NIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT NANCY PELOSI
IS DOING WITH THAT ODD STANDING
UP GRINDING HER TEETH, DOING
THIS WITH IT.
BUT IT IS THE LAST TIME WE WILL
SEE HER IN THE SPEAKER'S CHAIR.
THAT I GUARANTEE YOU.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS ACTUALLY THE
BEST MOMENT BECAUSE IT WAS THE
LAST TIME WE WILL SEE HER THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, KELLYAN